foreign
the question that I want to ask was
as the solo dirt bag traveler get up and
go anytime
marriage now what happened I mean I'm
not saying that in a bad way but how did
you personally arrive at a point where
you're like okay I think this is the
next step
it's a good question and I wish there
could be some sort of replicable lesson
here you know that if you just do this
during a pandemic you'll meet your soul
mate but I just through dumb luck and a
dating app I I met my person you know I
met my soulmate during the pandemic it's
funny she's from Kansas I'm from Kansas
I've sort of been
searching for my Kansas girl on the
other side of the world and she was on
the other side of the world she was
living in Europe when pandemic happened
she came back to be close to her family
I was living close to my family we were
both sort of bored on a dating app one
day and it's like wait a second really
you're out there and it just went from
zero to let's get married in in no time
flat uh and so so in a way I just I met
the right person and it was great but I
think
I think just being open to that and and
realizing that was a thing I I think
as a dirtbag traveler and I've always
been a proud Dirtbag traveler there's
some some compromises you make in life
where you think
I am sort of sacrificing traditional
love for an interesting life and for
freedom and for flexibility and for the
ability to be anywhere at any time and
then you meet this person then you meet
your person it's like all those song
lyrics that you sort of rolled your eyes
at when in your 20s
suddenly makes sense it's like yeah yeah
sure give me a give me an old 60s Motown
song about love and that's that's what
I'm experiencing with this person and so
it's great it's the ability to
experience something and it's not like I
fell in love for the first time but
experienced that full-throated
full-hearted all-in love when I was when
I was pushing 50 was fun to see and
there's almost a travel parallel in that
in that sense in that you're always
seeking newness and I think I sort of
had a scab over my heart in a certain
sense because travel was so rewarding
and the freedom to travel was so
rewarding that I didn't realize I could
have it both and then suddenly I met
this person it's like oh and I think
when I proposed marriage I used
waltman's line you know I give you my
hand I give you my love more precious
than money will you come travel with me
shall we stick together as long as we
live if I didn't quote that directly I
paraphrased it because it's like yes
this is my person come travel with me
and come stay here with me too we have a
good life here in Kansas as well but
it's interesting and this probably
doesn't happen to most people I think a
lot of people really get into the love
mindset in that in that age that
features romantic comedies in your 20s
or whatever
but for some reason I thought the uh the
price of an interesting life was not
having traditional love relationship and
I was I was blown away to have a to fall
in love during the pandemic with my
person so
so let's dig a bit further on that
you're an excellent writer a man of
words a man of letters
how would you describe this
experience what was different how were
you different in responding to it as you
said not your first time falling in love
and love can also be an umbrella term
that covers a lot of different species
of what we might call love so what what
was different about you about her about
the two of you
you've had you've been exposed to a lot
of things in a lot of places
so what was it
I enjoyed being a bachelor back when I
was one
man and I've told my wife sometimes we
should have met 10 years earlier like
this 10 years would have been way more
interesting if you would have been in it
right and she said yeah I'm not sure if
we were getting ready I'm not sure if I
would have been ready for you and you
for me and so I think sometimes maybe
I'm a person who just needed to grow a
little bit you know to be more
open-hearted to be ready to meet this
person and I'm suddenly this believer in
fate
but I I sort of needed to work through
some things I needed to travel some and
just sort of get a sense to where I
realized I needed that you know that I
wouldn't have lived a complete life I I
needed my other half you know I needed
that full-throated open-hearted love and
it sort of caught me by surprise but now
that I have it it just doesn't make
sense it's like what I was what was I
doing all those years before I met my
wife so
does that answer your question are you I
think it does I think it does I suppose
I'm hearing the
you being more prepared on some level
even though it perhaps it wasn't a
conscious preparation for this but
having changed over time become more
open-hearted
you also
I would imagine probably thought through
what proposing and getting married would
mean
I suppose if you have any other pieces
of advice or suggestions for folks out
there maybe one who you're talking to
who is no I'd say getting to if not
having already passed the midpoint in
life
who has not yet arrived there all right
what would you say
I think that that needs to be worked
through I think too many people in all
societies marry too soon because it's
sort of expected I think it will
complete them somehow
I think working through ambivalence or
through uncertainty is an important
thing you know I had
I had a concussion I wrecked a
motorcycle in Asia in 2019 and it led me
into some post-concussive depression and
I think sometimes that experience I
think actually I'm not sure how
hardwired for depression I am I'm sort
of this reflexive Optimist but it also
felt seasonal depression sometimes and
so it was probably always there but just
sort of working through sort of having
my my head knocked in a little bit and
being
you know sort of working through dealing
with aloneness and sadness and realizing
that being completely an island away
from other people is not necessarily a
desirable thing and I don't think that
depression necessarily is going to
compel someone to just marry the next
person who walks in the door I think I
was very lucky to meet someone who's
very well suited to be with me and I
with her
but I think
working through those just realizing
it's something you need like I think I
think I realized I needed that kind of
love before I met my wife and when I met
my wife it's like oh well there you are
right and so I worry my nightmare is
that I may have met her 10 years earlier
and not recognized the the way that she
completed my way of being in the world
and so I would say don't don't be afraid
of those negatives and the sadness and
and sort of trying but but be honest
with yourself I think sometimes maybe
men have a problem with this more than
women is that that self-sufficiency
trying to be completely self-contained
and having freedom and not really having
obligations to other people in life
doesn't always yield happiness in a way
that that sort of yoking yourself to
somebody else's life can and so I can
speak with expertise about travel less
so with love I still feel like I was
really blindsided by it and again very
lucky to to have experienced it in the
full-throated way that I did
but I think just sort of working through
it and realizing that complete
Independence and and sort of being
pinched off from other people in the
world is not necessarily the best way to
live